Vous n'aimez pas qui vous êtes?
Vous cherchez à vous revaloriser?
Une seule méthode:
exercice physique,
développement intellectuel,
don de soi-même
et méditation.
Vous avez du temps à perdre
avec ces simagrées?
Moi non plus.
Pourquoi s'épuiser
à devenir une meilleure personne
quand on peut éprouver
la même satisfaction
en rabaissant simplement les autres?
Des milliers de personnes
ont déjà choisi de se revaloriser
en dénigrant les autres.
Pourquoi pas vous?
Dénigrer, d'accord.
Mais qui?
Pourquoi pas moi?
Ou moi?
Ou bien moi?
Ou encore moi?
Avec Victim' Express,
je serai la personne qui correspond le mieux
à vos critères de détestation.
J'aimerais bien quelqu'un qui porte
des pantacourts,
c'est possible?
-Je pense que c'est dans nos cordes.
Pas besoin de raison valable,
c'est le résultat qui compte.
Et si vous avez besoin d'aide,
nous sommes là pour vous conseiller.
Sinon je peux vous proposer quelqu'un
qui ait des goûts musicaux
un peu différents des vôtres.
Ça marche bien.
C'est bien.
Comme ça je vais pouvoir juger
toute sa personnalité à partir de ça.
Vous êtes un geek, un nerd?
Pas de problème, notre service est présent
sur les réseaux sociaux.
Avant, j'étais pas bien,
Puis j'ai découvert Victim'Express
Maintenant je me trouve toujours
pas terrible
mais je trouve les autres pires donc...